des satellites des prototypes de rover
le laboratoire l'atmo spécialisé dans
l'observation spatiale et de
l'atmosphère fêtait ce jeudi 23 mai à
guyancourt ses 10 ans avec ses
partenaires
l'occasion de montrer les travaux
réalisés sur le site depuis ses débuts
ça représente aujourd'hui 10 missions
spatiales qui tourne autour de la terre
ou qui sont partis explorer le système
solaire et dans lequel le laboratoire où
était à l'origine du concept ou créer un
instrument ou un en charge l'analyse
opérationnelle des données parmi les
projets réalisés certains chercheurs
installés sur le site on travaillait sur
un satellite baptisé mars express
l'appareil collecte en ce moment des
données sur l'atmosphère de la planète
rouge
le satellite est en orbite autour de
mars et puis il se met à regarder une
étoile dans la nuit et fait étoiles il
va l'avoir tout doucement descendre
derrière l'horizon et le spectre que
l'on enregistre de cette étoile est en
fait modulée par la présence des
composants gazeuse dans l'atmosphère de
mars donc on est capable de déduire la
température la quantité d'ozone la
quantité de dioxyde de carbone qui est
le composé principal de l'atmosphère
cette journée permettait également de
montrer les futurs projets qui vont
animer le centre sur les prochaines
années
en 2020 ce cube va être lâché dans
l'espace a pris moins de trois ans
d'existence
son objectif mesurer les flux solaire
entre le soleil et la terre
on a toutes les composantes d'un
satellite mais miniaturisés donc on va
retrouver des fonctions classiques un
ordinateur de bord qui permet de faire
la communication entre les différentes
cartes du satellite
on va avoir une carte de communication
qui va permettre la communication entre
les éléments du satellite est le seul
avec des antennes et ensuite la dernière
partie donc on va y est associée une
charge utile donc des instruments
scientifiques qui vont pouvoir faire les
mesures pour le grand public d'autres
événements seront organisés tout au long
de l'année dans la structure le latmos
ouvrira notamment ses portes le 21
septembre prochain pour les journées du
patrimoine
[Applaudissements]